[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute geht es nochmal ein kurzes rezept
also das rezept ist kurz aber der
aufwand ist ein bisschen lang zu
silvester und zwar morgens gedacht was
machen wir denn jetzt noch an rezepten
und uns viel ein für die silvesternacht
ist es ja bestimmt ganz cool wenn man
glückskekse selber macht denn man kann
darf supereinfach sprüche darin
verstecken vielleicht auch früher nicht
früher neujahrsbotschaften oder aber
kann auch im spiel draus machen genau
die dinge die wir ihn nicht einhält ja
zum beispiel vorsätze und so weiter aber
ich finde es zum beispiel so eine
fragerunde ganz cool also man kann sehr
hinten sowie wahrheit oder pflicht weil
schon so eine frage keine ahnung was war
das schönste was wir in den letzten zehn
jahren passiert ist und dann kommt vom
murat die antwort ehrlich jetzt ja weißt
schon dass ich das nicht sagen
da wird noch mal ganz gut was sagen ja
also gerade ihnen gesagt hat herzlich
willkommen sallys welt ja du warst du
darfst tonlage so weit oben gerade mist
was die scheidung rausgeflogen möchte
das ja ich gehe manchmal mit der tonlage
hoch weil ich einfach so was nicht und
habe gedacht jetzt so gegen ende des
jahres muss man noch mal hoch also ich
zeig euch jetzt den teig das ist
wirklich ein ganz einfacher teig und die
herstellung ist im prinzip einfach ihr
müsst nur ein paar sachen beachten also
ein paar tipps damit eben die kekse
nichts zur berechnung beim zusammenlegen
aber dass ihr dad ich zeige euch hier
mal die zutaten für die glückskekse
brauche ich drei eiweiß 150 gramm
puderzucker eine prise salz 100 gramm
mehl etwas vanille extrakt und 50 gramm
flüssige butter für den teig nämlich
jetzt zuerst das eiweiß und gibt sie in
eine schüssel und das könnt ihr jetzt
gerne einfach mit einem schneebesen ein
bisschen aufschlagen genug salz
dazugeben
da brauchen wir auch da keine
küchenmaschine dass ihr
[Musik]
und wenn der schnee dann fast steif ist
kommt jetzt noch der puderzucker dazu
und den sie bis jetzt einfach kurz damit
die klümpchen befinden
dann kurz einrühren
jetzt kommt hier noch das mehl mit dazu
vanille extrakt oder die flüssige butter
ist cool aus hab ja und so einfach ist
kurzweilig hinkriegen aber jetzt ich
möchte die wäsche verboten und kam
später vom schwächer wochen ja noch
nicht dass es jetzt deine mama said
ich bin jetzt mit dem teig fertig und
jetzt könnt ihr denn entweder so lassen
oder ihr könnt den teig auch gerne
einfärben
wichtig ist jetzt nur dass ein bisschen
rot das heißt ich kann den kurz zur
seite stellen und die zeit können die
jetzt auch nutzen um zum beispiel eure
glücks botschaften vorzubereiten wir
haben jetzt bereits ausgedruckt und
zugeschnitten die müssen jetzt noch ein
bisschen kürzen
sie sollten halt auch klein genug sein
dass wir sie gleich zusammenfalten
reinlegen können aber groß genug dass
man sie lesen kann und natürlich müsst
ihr noch etwas vorbereiten
und zwar habe ich hier bereits
backpapier bemalt auf die rückseite da
sind jetzt lauter 8 cm große kreise
da bienen ausstecher benutzt aber ihr
könnt zum beispiel auch einen teller
nehmen
wichtig ist nur dass man das ganze
umdreht und auf diese seite dann den
teig gibt jetzt nehme ich immer einen
esslöffel vom teig das geht am besten
mit einem aktionäre oder auch ganz
normal mit dem esslöffel zum
verstreichen nämlich am liebsten eine
winkel palette oder es geht auch ganz
einfach mit einem messer oder der löffel
rückseite weniger bunte glückskekse
haben möchtet ist es einfach nur wichtig
verpasste zu verwenden weil die die
konsistenz vom teig nicht verändert da
kommen dann ein paar tropfen mit zum
teil werden verrührt und so könnt ihr
die bunten klecksen auch schön verteilt
jetzt nehme ich einen dreier gespann das
kommt jetzt direkt aufs backblech den
oben habe ich bereits auf 180 grad ober
unterhitze vorgeheizt jetzt kommen sie
in den ofen und je nach oben typ kommt
einem riff drauf an
sie brauchen zwischen vier und acht
minuten daran sollte leicht braun werden
daher gebe ich jetzt auch erst die un-
gefärbten in den backofen kann nach der
backzeit schauen und dann
anderen auch backen und gleich sehen wir
uns wieder denn da müssen wir sie gleich
verpacken
die ersten kekse sind jetzt fertig jetzt
gleich weitermachen
sie sitzt hier formen backblech und
jetzt vorsichtig vom backpapier lösen
da kommt jetzt direkt einspruch ein
ok man kann diese größe machen so
klappen und hier darüber hängen
[Musik]
okay da war jetzt zu lange drin der jets
gebrochen also ich brauchte also etwa
fünf bis fünfeinhalb minuten dann sind
sie perfekt aber das ist europa
[Musik]
und zwar immer noch etwas glitter mit
reinbringen möchte kann man die
glückskekse mit etwas kristall pulver
farbe sprühen
[Musik]
also jetzt sind die kekse fertig habe
übrigens ganz vergessen zu erwähnen ich
hatte ja ein instagram posting gemacht
und habe gefragt möchtet ihr bunte
glückskekse oder eher elegante schwarze
mit gold und so weiter und die
abstimmung war fast gleichauf deswegen
habe ich jetzt auch beides gemacht also
es war irgendwie so 51 zu 49 und ich
dachte com jetzt machen wir niemanden
traurig machen wir beide variationen
oder sonstigen eine 50 zu 50 war nicht
habe ich jetzt habe ich richtig sagt ja
ganz okay
so darf jetzt probieren ich muss zugeben
sie sind nicht so knusprig wie die man
kaufen kann ja es muss man auch sagen
also sind diese phase wobei teilweise
waren sehr knusprig aber ich finde es
jetzt auch gar nicht schlimm weil das
geht ja um die botschaft ich finde die
oft so hart du net die schlafräume japan
geht es manchmal dass da was drin ist
das ist ein einfacher sagt bei mir waren
extreme gemacht
kimi ist es war müssen ich probier jetzt
mal schmecken sie ganz klar also ganz
toll und ehrlich sagen
und jetzt lese ich mal meinen sprung von
jan lesen mancher werbesprüche von murat
und sprecher von mehr und wissen spruch
von dir will hat mehrere wörter und hat
auch wahrzeichen ja dann geschafft noch
nicht nur mit dem herzen sieht man gut
das wesentliche ist für die augen
unsichtbar war das land von wie der
kleine prinz
also aber diesmal wieder typische spiel
verstehen das war dem herrn bischof
seine spuren kannst du noch mal gucken
welches meine leute meine sprüche haben
meistens nur vierter
das kurz das ist auch von mir kein
kuchen ist auch keine lösung weil er
sich nochmal raus da dein glück
ihr müsst ihr halt alles später auf
essen ja indem man über andere schlecht
redet macht man sich selber nicht besser
sein als das alles pädagogen sprüchen
hast du mal richten gassenhauer von mira
kicker murad von präsident saleh ist
dasselbe gemeint ist lustig dann ist
also wirklich so pädagogisch angehaucht
ja ich bin okay ausgelassen habe ich
mich was ist aus
aber mir aber guck mal ein kurzer mensch
ist was ein kinderherz nicht verliert
okay ich habe so viel am morgen
vertreibt kummer und sorgen
wer viele schätze anhäuft hat viel zu
verlieren ist ein weiser spruch er
studiert auch alle jetzt die ganze zeit
und schmecken mit nicht klassiker hat es
aber einer von der einzigen tag kummer
und ärger erspart weil viele schätze
anhäuft hat viel zu belasten du bist wie
ich habe nur noch mal zur sicherheit
kaum ein stück spruch
kein chef ist auch keine lösung ist auch
cool war ja dass meine sprünge kann
manchmal sehen ganz gleich kommt hätte
ich aber noch ein bisschen paar mehr nur
döner macht schöner kann es sein dass du
das geschrieben habe sei ja also also
ein letzter com na ja hier stinkt es
habe ich für dich gemacht kommen als
abschluss hier die telefonnummer vom
istanbul kredithaus da kann ja kein
wilder bestellen telefonnummer istanbul
brühl haus 0 sieg 25 495 7 770 na ja das
letzte seiner box bestellen genau es war
ein schöner abschluss ja jetzt könnt ihr
alle hier die kekse auf essen und falls
ihr die auch nach machen wollt dann geht
einfach auf salehs - block dave da steht
noch mal das ganz genaue rezept ihr
könnt sie ja auch machen und zu bereiten
ein foto schießen und uns markieren und
wir wünschen euch alles liebe und gute
fürs neue jahr aber ein bisschen ist da
noch weil am 31 kommt ein richtig cooles
video aber wir verraten doch nix macht
ist einfach sein zu schließen und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal bitte name
aber coletti auch mal so eine hochzeit
zum beispiel oder zum verschenken
geburtstag polar mit guten sprüngen
nicht gut aber ich spüre hier mit viel
besser als sein in der zitrone orange
rein tonkabohne tonkabohnen
[Musik]